there are hundreds of different Ramen
all over the world Misa Ramen Shu Ramen
Ramon Ramen suken Ramen and many many
more but this is flying
[Music]
Ramen but why does it
fly meet Christopher proprietor of one
of the most unique Ramen joints in
Berlin he's mastering the Japanese craft
of Ramen from the comfort of his flat
first time I ever had Ramen was as
instant Ramen in high school didn't
really look like a lot but then when I
tasted it for the first time it really
blew my mind immediately even though it
was just this plain instant Ramen in
that case but it was really something i'
had never tasted before in 2006
Christopher traveled to Japan as a
student and got his first taste of
authentic Japanese ramen it was really
like I imagined it to be extremely
flavorful and surprising at the same
time which yeah kind of impressed me so
much that I yeah always dreamed of of
cooking Ramen myself obsessed with all
things Japanese Cuisine Christopher
spent the next 20 years eating cooking
and developing his own Ramen recipes cuz
I had like a social media account
Instagram account for which I documented
how I cooked Japanese style and often
experimented with different Ramen uh
recipes documenting how I was cooking
each component and how it tasted then in
2020 Co hit the world I couldn't work in
my my main job so I had a lot of time
and people were asking me whether they
could have a taste of my Ramen and since
I'm living in the second floor and I
didn't want anyone to walk through our
building I had the idea of using a red
bucket uh to lower it from my living
room to the customers waiting downstairs
at the pavement the inspiration for the
red bucket actually came from a very
famous Ramen Shop in Fukuoka Japan who
uses a blue bucket as a sign outside of
the door to show whenever it's out the
Ramen Shop is open the bucket is red
since I wanted to buy a blue one but the
shop nearby only had a red one
so prais for his mix of German and
Japanese flavors Christopher's Ramen
became loved by German Foodies so much
so he has launched food Technique Bin
which sells prepacked Ramen kits that
ship worldwide for you to make it home
the Japanese ramen differs from the one
that I have from the ingredients used so
it's mostly using a lot of different
dried fish that you rarely find outside
of Japan so it's nibosi dried sardines
and since it's mostly made with this
type of ingredient it really was
something which I wanted to bring to
Germany to let other people taste it how
do you begin to make your Ramen
Christopher first step when making ramen
is the noodles cuz they uh need the
longest and I like to age them for 2 to
3 days which makes them a bit better
from the texture side the second step is
the soup which I make which takes
roughly a day and then the freshest and
the last ingredients that I prepare are
the toppings which are the ones that you
find on top of the ramen so the meat the
egg and the different types of
vegetables onions for instance my
favorite Ramen variety is mostly made
with chicken bones and pork bones and
since I love Seafood I also add muscles
which is uh like this double broth which
is also often used in Japan and which
you rarely find in Germany making ramen
really takes quite a long time so often
four to 5 days it's quite a smelly
business so my neighbors and my family
were quite happy when I started to move
certain steps uh to an outside kitchen
will you keep the red bucket now that
the pandemic is over I still love using
the red buckets it's exciting to see how
happy it makes the customers and it's
kind of what I enjoy most and then it's
also a good way to interact with the
customers asking them for feedback so it
really is has become a key Cornerstone
of of the whole Ramen business that I'm
running I cannot imagine getting bored
of ramen there are so many new varieties
I don't know about yet and so many new
techniques I could learn and ramen is
such a simple dish but using those
techniques to make those different
components a little bit better makes the
whole thing um that
[Music]
exciting